the tan suit type fake scandals about Joe
Biden are quickly ramping up. Last week,
we covered Tucker Carlson's explosive reporting
about how supposedly Joe and Jill Biden don't
really love each other. Their marriage is merely a
stage managed public relations strategy. That was
last week. This week, we have a clip from Newsmax
host Greg Kelly saying that Joe Biden's choice of
dog isn't very presidential, referring, of course,
to the Biden's senior German shepherd champ and
bringing on a panel to discuss this
important topic, saying Biden's dog
looks like he's from a junkyard. Check this out.
Did you see the dog? Let's I want to show you
something I noticed. Doesn't he look a little
a little rough? Oh, I love dogs, but this dog
needs a bath and a comb and all kinds of love and
care. I've never seen a dog in the White House
like this. I remember, buddy. I remember Millie.
I remember lots of dogs, but not a dog who seems
I don't know I don't know how
much love and care he is getting.
Let's bring in the Historias. I love having
fun with this, obviously, but I do want to
talk about some stuff. Craig Shirley, Reagan
biographer, presidential historian. Greg,
welcome back. And Doug Wead, presidential
historian and former adviser to George H.W.
Bush. That's the White House where I remember
Millie. Millie had like a staff and they really
took care of her very beautiful dog. This dog
looks like from I'm sorry, from the junkyard.
And I love that dog, but he looks like he's not
being well cared for, you know, not not at all.
Thank you for having us. Now, he looks very dirty
and disheveled and very unlike a presidential dog
like Millie or Victory or something else
in the past in the in the White House.
This isn't the right type of dog for the
White House. Trump didn't have a dog.
Trump seemed unable to understand a thing
about human dog relationships. A junkyard dog,
which one of the so-called presidential
experts brought onto the panel to discuss this
says was a disheveled and dirty dog. This is
Obama's tan suit redux, but extra stupid because
it's not even about Biden. It's about Biden's
dog. This is Obama's mustard. Choices are Bujji.
Again, Joe Biden has the wrong type of dog for
the White House and the dog doesn't look right
and look at what they are doing. They have a panel
on which Craig Shirley, a presidential historian,
says champ looks very dirty and disheveled and
very unlike a presidential dog. Do you really need
an historian to tell you that? Or maybe you could
get just one of the people who held one of those
ten foot Trump flags in Palm Beach, Florida, on
Presidents Day? I don't know that you need an
expert if this is the type of opinion that you're
looking for, another manufactured right wing
scandal, these during presidential administrations
of Democrats, these completely imaginary right
wing scandals are as certain, I guess, as death
and taxes, death taxes and tan suit type scandals.
Now, was this a deliberate deflection from the Ted
Cruz fiasco that was going on? I don't know. Ah,
right wingers against rescue dogs. Now it has to
be a designer dog from a breeder to meet their
standards and to be suitable for a president.
As far as they're concerned, this is more
confirmation about how different these two sides
of American politics are. I'm the first to say
on many issues, Democrats and Republicans are too
similar. There's not enough daylight between them.
But we've talked about real policy differences.
And when it comes to substance versus fluff,
under Barack Obama, the scandals were tan suits,
mustard types, that type of thing. Under Trump,
it was, hey, what about the emoluments clause?
What about asking foreign powers for help, getting
reelected? What about putting the U.S. on the
road to authoritarianism? Those were the concerns.
Now, Joe Biden is president and it's
Joe and Joe Biden's love is fabricated
and Joe Biden has the wrong type of dog who's
dirty. And to be clear, there are already
serious critiques of Joe Biden, but they're not
the ones that right wing media wants to make.
As I've been saying for weeks, what is going on
with covid relief? That's a real question. Joe
Biden said right away checks are going out. It's
almost March. There's still no deal. That's real.
Biden said he would stop deportations
in order to figure out what to do about
immigration. He did one executive order. A
judge blocked it and he's done nothing else.
He could do more executive orders. We talked about
that in detail earlier today. There are criticisms
of Joe Biden. They're not the ones that Fox News
own and Newsmax want to make and the desperation
of. The right wing to make any Democrat look
bad is pathetic if you have to insult a dog,
you're really hitting rock bottom and these
people are truly and completely disgusting.